Nicole Richie is that you I'm just being
me no you're not seeing double that's
Nicole and Joe Madden's 15 year old
daughter Harlow Nicole's sharing this
pick on Mother's Day celebrating all the
women in her life including her mom
Brenda and newlywed sister Sophia but
it's the rare snap of Harlow that has
our attention she's the spitting image
of her mama I'm a very classy lady
Nicole and Joel have been notoriously
private when it comes to their kiddos
keeping both Harlow and her 13 year old
brother Sparrow out of the spotlight I
was always able to maintain a level of
privacy and able to have my my own life
Nicole's only given small glimpses of
life with their little ones over the
years I mean they're getting to an age
now where they're understanding what
what we do and you know they're normal
kids they have an appreciation yeah it's
very relaxed it's very normal
we got a dog and you know it's very like
it's very very normal so as they head
toward adulthood will Harlow and Sparrow
go into the family business well
businesses they could always try music
like they're good Charlotte frontman dad
Joel and Uncle Benji
[Applause]
always complain
then there's Nicole's dad their grandpa
Lionel Richie
[Music]
or there's mom's career path in fashion
Nicole's brand is actually named House
of Harlow after her first born that's
how I like to dress I just love to uh be
comfortable be comfortable and have fun
um and so that's kind of what I try to
accomplish in the collection well
Nicole's got some thoughts about her
kids following in anyone's footsteps I
see them developing into themselves and
I'm very careful about my mom used to
always say anytime I would do something
she'd be like you're just like me or
you're just like your dad or you're just
like and I was like stop saying that so
I have been really conscious to not say
that around my kids but even if Nicole
doesn't say it to Harlow she still
thinking it because they do have clothes
in common my daughter loves fashion but
she has her own she's got her own style
it doesn't have anything to do with me
um she takes my clothes all the time I
have just started writing an n in it
with a Sharpie on all of my stuff oh
yeah yeah yeah it has become very very
bad she's wearing my current clothes now
you know she's just like what do you
have that's what I want I'm taking it
and then I gotta go in her closet steal
it back and no doubt the mother daughter
look like twins when Harlow steals
Nicole's clothes
[Music]
thank you